RACHEL O'MEARA:
Welcome, everyone.
Thank you so much
for coming today.
I'm Rachel O'Meara, and I am
usually in the San Francisco
office, but today I'm
really happy to be here
in Mountain View to
host Chris Guillebeau.
He's here on a tour
for his third book,
called "The Happiness
of Pursuit,"
and today he's going to
talk to us about this book
and what it means to find
passion in your life.
The people that he's met through
his travels of every country
in the world, which is
awesome-- he's actually
encountered quite
a few people that I
think he'll share
some of those stories
today with us about what
he's learned from them,
and how they've harnessed
their own passions,
and to have meaning
in their own lives
through quests of knowing and
wanting more for themselves
through travel and other ways.
I hosted say Chris two
years ago in San Francisco
for his second book, "The
$100 Startup," so some of you
may know that.
And it's just a real pleasure
to have him back here today.
So, Chris, I would love you to
come on up, and we welcome you.
Thank you.
CHRIS GUILLEBEAU: Thank you.
Thanks a lot.
Thank you so much, Rachel,
and good afternoon.
So glad to be back at the
Googleplex for my third visit,
actually.
I was here for the
first book, also,
and a couple years ago
for "$100 Startup,"
so I'm thrilled to
see all you guys,
and hello to everyone
who's watching elsewhere.
So what I'd love
to do is, I know
people are having
lunch, which is great.
I don't want to give
you a long lecture,
but I'll talk for
maybe 15, 20 minutes,
I'll tell you a little bit
about quests and adventures,
and why I pursued
my journey, and what
I learned along the way.
And then we'll do some question
and attempted answer-- QAA.
So sometimes it goes
better than others,
but I'm sure here at
Google, it will be awesome,
and you might get the chance
to help me with an answer.
And as we begin, I do, actually,
have a question for all of you.
A very serious,
important question.
How many of you have ever played
the video game "Super Mario
Bros.?"
You raise your hand.
Yeah.
OK, I was expecting a pretty
high per capita group,
which is great.
"Super Mario Bros." is a
trans-generational video game.
It first came out 29 years ago.
I remember playing it at the
age of six with my grandmother,
and my dad also
liked to play, but he
wasn't as good as grandma.
So whenever I got stuck
on the water level,
I would pass the
controller to grandma,
and she would help me out
and give it back to me.
And for all of you
who played this game--
and it's OK if you haven't-- you
may remember that there are all
kinds of stages and levels
and obstacles and enemies
and puzzles, and all these kind
of things that you have to do.
And you, this Italian plumber,
are on a quest, essentially.
And you're not doing
this for no reason.
Some of it seems a
little bit random,
but there's actually a
purpose for everything
that you're doing.
So, open question to the
smart audience at Google.
What is Mario trying
to accomplish?
What's he trying to do?
AUDIENCE: Thank you,
Mario, but your princess
is in another castle.
CHRIS GUILLEBEAU: That's right.
That's what he encounters
first, and then he
encounters it seven more times.
But he's actually trying to
save the princess, right?
To save the princess.
Who is Mario's adversary?
AUDIENCE: Bowser.
CHRIS GUILLEBEAU: Bowser.
Does anyone remember that?
Great.
So if you know Bowser, and
it's OK if you don't, you
may recall that he's this super
large turtle who's really upset
about something, and
he's been determined
to cause disorder in
the Mushroom Kingdom.
But does anyone know why?
Does anyone know
why Bowser is so
agitated that he had to do this?
There's actually
not a good answer.
There's not a good
reason, right?
And we as players are just
kind of thrown into this world,
and we get this controller,
and there's Mario,
and there's these enemies.
And we understand that the
princess has been kidnapped,
and that's all we care about,
because we have to overcome
these stages to get to that end.
And as you mentioned, we
don't get there right away.
It takes some time
before we get there.
OK, so how many of you have
ever seen any Star Wars film?
Once again, raise your hand.
Great.
Pretty fair assumption.
Any Indiana Jones film?
Any Lord of the Rings film?
That's great.
Is there any one person
here who has never
seen any one of these films?
Star Wars, Star
Trek, Indiana Jones.
AUDIENCE: I met someone
who hadn't seen Star Wars.
CHRIS GUILLEBEAU: So did I. I
did two nights, ago, actually.
I was in Milwaukee,
and there was
one person who raised their
hand, and I was like, great.
My next book will be
written all for you,
and you and I will have
a meetup of two people,
and we'll talk about it.
But for now, I'm going
to talk to everyone else.
So, thankfully, everyone
here knows a little bit
about Star Wars or Star
Trek or Indiana Jones.
And it's OK if you don't
remember all the details,
because all of
these stories have
a number of things in common.
All of these stories, just
like Mario, have a destination.
They have a goal.
There's something that the
hero or the group of heroes
is trying to accomplish.
There's a princess who
needs to be rescued.
There's a galaxy
that must be saved.
There is something that
has to be reclaimed,
or something has been
stolen or captured,
and you have to go
out and seek this.
And it's going to
take some time.
There are lots of milestones
and stages along the way.
There are lots of challenges.
In fact, challenge is the
essence of these stories.
Challenge is the
essence of adventure.
It's all about the challenge.
And that's what we want as
viewers, as readers of books,
as video game players.
We want the challenge.
We don't want it to be too easy.
We don't want a scenario in
which the heroes are sent out
from the village, and
there's this huge sendoff,
and then they go off
on this epic voyage,
and they have to fight some
terrible enemy at the end.
But the epic voyage is
actually really simple,
and there's a nonstop
flight to their destination.
And then they come to the
end, and the dragon is asleep.
And then they just
kind of take the ring
or whatever it is, and they
go back, and they're like,
yeah, it was supposed
to be really tough,
but we did it in one day.
Great.
That would be the most
boring movie, right?
That would be the
most boring story,
because challenge,
once again, is
the essence of these adventures.
So one more thing that I haven't
mentioned in all these stories
thus far is that all of these
stories, so far, are not true.
All of these stories are
mythological stories.
They're fiction,
fantasy-- something
that has been created
for our entertainment,
for our enjoyment.
I hope I'm not breaking
any news to anyone.
Sometimes I speak to audience--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
CHRIS GUILLEBEAU: I know.
No, I wasn't going to
mention that, actually,
because sometimes there are
children-- they aren't here
today, but I just don't
touch holidays at all.
So it doesn't mean that
these stories lack value.
We can still be
entertained, as I said.
We can be inspired, even.
There's lots of good
things about them,
but fundamentally,
they're not true.
About 10 years ago, I became
interested in the study
and pursuit of real life
adventures or real life
quests-- things that
involved epic journeys.
Things that involved
a lot of challenge.
something that
had been lost that
had to be reclaimed,
or something that had
to be accomplished
through a long series
of obstacles and tasks,
but were actually being
done by real people.
And I kind of stumbled
into this myself,
through my own quest,
which was to visit
every country in the world.
And for the past
10 and 1/2 years,
as I've been doing
some other things,
I've been making steady
progress toward that goal.
And when I first had the
idea, it wasn't so much
that I had just been to
one country and I said,
oh, I want to go to
the 192 that remain.
I kind of came to it
out of a lot of travel.
So I lived in West
Africa for a few years.
I was working as an aid
worker in Sierra Leone,
traveled a bit in
the region there.
Then I traveled in Europe a bit.
I'd been to like
30 countries or so.
I was always a big list maker.
I was always writing
down lists and my tasks
and to dos and things.
And once I started
traveling, I started
making a list of all
the places I had been.
And as I got to, like, 30
countries, I was like, wow,
wouldn't it be cool to
go to 100 countries?
Sometime in my life-- I'm
very goal oriented, also--
and I was like,
sometime in my life,
I want to go to 100 countries.
And then I started
working closer to that.
And then I realized, well,
maybe 100 countries is not
that challenging, because
I can pick and choose
which countries to go to.
I can avoid the hard ones.
If I get stuck, I'll
just go somewhere else.
And so then I decided
to take on the goal
of going to every
country in the world.
So perhaps the
first observation is
that these kinds of
visions for quests
and these kinds of
grand adventures-- you
don't always know the whole
story in the beginning.
You don't always
have the confidence
that you develop later to
take on something really big.
The confidence comes
through experience.
So in my case, out
of a love of travel
and out of a love of lists,
as I traveled, as I wrote down
my countries, that's when I was
like, I want to take on more.
I want to do something further.
I want to not just
travel, but I want
to create some
structure around this.
I want to create some
parameters around that.
So that made a big
difference for me.
And then, along
the way, as happens
with every quest,
every good adventure,
I met a lot of really
amazing, remarkable people.
And I actually began
this journey just
as kind of a solo
independent traveler.
I was super introverted.
I didn't have a blog.
I didn't have books.
There was no public
persona with any of this.
And about halfway through--
maybe about 70 countries in,
actually-- I started
writing about it.
And then, just by
default, I started
learning from lots
of other people
who came along to
participate, or to read,
or to engage, or to
challenge me on something,
or to meet me
somewhere in the world.
And then by the time
I arrived at the end
of the journey--
again, 10 years later,
which was last year--
I flew to Norway,
my final country, number 193.
And by the time I went there,
it was a good representation
of how the project had
transformed, because I started
just doing stuff by myself,
and then at the end,
there were about 200 people
who came along with me.
And we had an end
of the world party
in Norway to celebrate not just
the accomplishment of my quest,
but all these
different people who
were doing fun
things themselves.
So I started studying
quests and adventures,
and started to
understand, OK, why
do people pursue
this grand journey?
Even if it's not
travel related, why
do they choose to
embark upon something
that will change their
lives, that will also involve
a lot of challenge,
as I mentioned,
that may involve
sacrifice, or may require
them to trade something off?
Like, why do they do that, and
what can we learn from that?
How can we apply
that to our lives,
even if we don't want to visit
every country in the world
or do something like that?
So I met a lot of
people first doing
some really just crazy,
incredible kind of things,
and I called these the
"oh my God" stories.
So I met a guy who ran 250
marathons in a single year.
I met the young woman
who's actually a teenager,
or was a teenager, when
she sailed around the world
by herself in a small
sailboat, becoming the youngest
person ever to do that.
I talked with a
team in Brisbane,
Australia led by
a classical music
DJ who had spent about 28 years
trying to produce the world's
largest symphony,
and the symphony
required more than 800
performers, multiple choirs,
lots of specialized
instrumentation.
It was just this
crazy thing that
hadn't been performed
anywhere in the world for more
than 40 years until
they put it together.
And so there were all
these failures and missteps
and things along the
way, until they finally
produced that symphony to a
sold out crowd three years ago.
I met the guy who took a 17
year vow of silence, initially
as an environmental
protest, initially
as he was troubled through an
oil spill in the San Francisco
Bay.
But then, more than just that.
More of a self
discovery project.
More of a travel project as
he earned a Master's degree
and a Ph.D. all
without speaking,
and advocated on behalf of
the cause that had founded.
So I heard all of these
incredible stories,
but then I also
heard a second group
of stories that were more
about ordinary people
just like me doing really
interesting things.
So people that
didn't necessarily
want to take a 17 year vow of
silence, who didn't necessarily
want to sail around
the world or whatever.
Maybe they had a job.
Maybe they had a
family or whatever.
But they were still
able, somehow,
to cultivate the value of
adventure and their lives,
or to create a quest
for themselves.
And so my favorite
story in that regard
is the story of Sasha Martin.
And Sasha is a young mother
who's living in Oklahoma now,
but she grew up in Europe
and some different places.
And after she married
and settled down,
she had a daughter.
She wanted to raise
her family with
an international perspective.
But she wasn't able to travel.
And so she was trying to
figure out, how can I do this?
How can I show my daughter
a world beyond Oklahoma,
even though I'm not
able to take her
to every country in
the world or whatever?
So Sasha had a
culinary arts degree,
and she decided to cook
a meal from every country
in the world.
And so she created a quest
for herself and her family,
starting from when her
daughter was six months old
and first beginning
to eat solid food.
Her first meal is
Afghan chicken,
starting with
Afghanistan, A, and then
going through the alphabet,
country by country,
once a week, for more
than three years.
And Sasha talks
about how this quest
has transformed
her family's life.
It wasn't just about food.
It was also about culture.
It was about people.
They would spend the week
studying recipes and playing
music from that country,
and maybe meeting anyone
from that area who is
either from that country
or had been there.
And then Sasha started posting
her recipes online and inviting
other people to participate,
either for the whole project
or just for a little
bit in their own way.
So again, she talks
about how this
has made a huge
difference in her life,
because she didn't
just decide-- and this
is the key part--
she didn't just
decide to cook a
bunch of foreign food.
She created a quest, and
she had these parameters,
and she had these
specific things.
OK, I'm going to do every single
country, no exceptions, right?
So I met all these great people.
There are many other stories
in the book and on my website,
and I learned a lot of lessons.
I'm a slow learner.
I took me 10 years.
But I did learn a few things.
And I will tell you just
two to three things,
and then we'll have
a conversation.
So first thing--
first lesson-- is
that if you have a dream,
if you have this crazy idea,
you must believe in it,
even if no one else does.
So when I had the idea to go
to every country in the world,
that's kind of
what it felt like.
It felt like this crazy idea.
It was like, this just sounds
totally ridiculous and absurd,
but I couldn't stop
thinking about it.
And I realized that
if I didn't pursue it,
I would always regret it.
And that knowledge-- that
fear of regret-- kind of
drove me to say yes.
And I talked to
lots of other people
who used very similar language.
There's a guy from
Portland, Maine
whose crazy idea was
to walk across America.
And he wasn't even sure,
like, how does that work?
How much time does that take?
Has anyone done this before?
It was this crazy idea that
wouldn't leave him alone.
And so one morning, he
left his home in Maine,
and he started walking.
And seven a half months later,
he arrived in San Francisco.
And I talked to him
throughout the whole journey.
I talked to in the
beginning, and in the middle,
and in the end.
And I asked him, what
were the challenges like,
and how did that go?
And he said something
that stayed with me
for the rest of my journey.
He said, you know, there were
lots of external challenges.
It was hard on the body to
get used to walking that much.
Lots of things went wrong.
There were some emotional
challenges as well.
He had just had
a breakup, and he
was kind of processing
all of this.
He said, but what I
realized about two weeks in,
once I stopped
complaining and grumbling
about the whole
thing-- he said, I
realized that my task
was pretty simple.
All I had to do was
walk, essentially.
And if I did nothing else--
if I got up every morning
and I made a little bit of
progress, then eventually,
I would reach the goal.
Eventually, I would
arrive in San Francisco
and achieve that goal--
reach that destination.
And it sounded really simple,
but it's kind of stayed with me
for the final two
years of my quest,
because that's how I
felt it was for me, too.
All I had to do was
get to 193 countries.
And I had my list of countries,
and I was making progress.
And if I got stuck
somewhere, eventually I'd
have to overcome
that challenge, but I
could go and do
some others first.
And I liked the logical,
analytical progress of it.
It's something
that related to me.
So just keep going.
You have to believe
in your dream,
even if no one else does.
Second lesson, discontent
is a very powerful force
for positive change.
So a lot of people
that I talked to
came to their quest
or their project out
of a sense of discontent-- out
of a sense of being unsettled.
It doesn't mean that
they were miserable,
necessarily, but it
does mean that they
had kind of a stirring or a
yearning for something more.
They kind of felt
like, I have this idea,
or maybe I don't even actually
know what the full idea is yet,
but I want to do something
else with my life.
I want my like to
count, and I really
want to live with urgency.
So they found a way to combine
that discontent with something
specific-- with something
that was inspiring to them
with something that they
could take action on,
and with something that had
those parameters, as I talked
about, because the parameters
really was key to the quest.
And the last lesson that
I'll share with you before we
do question and
attempted answers
is that thinking about
the end of our lives
can help us with the
rest of our lives.
So a lot of the
people that were drawn
to these kind of journeys--
for some reason or another,
they had always been
sensitive to death.
And some of them had had a close
brush with death themselves.
Others had experienced
the loss of a family
member or a close friend.
But they all talked about
living with urgency.
They talked about wanting
their lives to count.
There was a woman in the Midwest
named Phoebe [? Snetsinger ?].
And Phoebe had raised a family.
And when she was almost
40, she was thinking,
I want to do something
for myself now.
It was great to raise
my family, but I
want to do something
more for me.
And so she started pursuing the
hobby of bird watching, which
is all about being in nature,
and exploring the environment,
and seeing as many birds as
possible and recording them.
And just as she
was kind of getting
into this new thing
for herself, she
received what was initially a
terminal diagnosis of cancer.
And the very first
thing she thought
when she received that
diagnosis was, oh no.
There's so many more
things I wanted to do.
There's so many things I feel
are left undone in my life.
And so she resolved to
spend the rest of her life--
however much time that was--
traveling, and going abroad
for the first time, and seeing
as many birds as she could,
and going into the
rainforest, and the jungles,
and going to Africa, and the
Amazon, and all these places.
And fortunately for Phoebe,
her diagnosis was premature,
and she lived more than
20 years after that.
And she spent those 20
years pursuing this quest.
And right before she
died, she actually
set the Guinness World
Record of seeing more birds
than anyone else in
history, a record that
had previously only
been held by men.
So she had really
chosen to focus
on that topic of
urgency-- of how can I
do something for myself?
How can I find something
that's worth living for,
and how can I embark on that?
And how can I craft
my life around that?
And the very last
thing I want to say
is I know that some
of you have probably
written books yourself.
Rachel is writing a
book, and some of you
probably want to write books.
And I always think it's
important for authors
to say why they wrote
any particular book.
And in the case of
all of my books,
the goal is always the same.
I don't want people to
read them and say, oh,
that was a great book.
I would love someone
to read the book,
or come to a talk like this,
or connect with someone
in our community, and say, yeah.
I read that, or I
came to that, and then
I went and thought
differently about something,
or then I took some
action in my life.
Maybe this made a
small difference.
Maybe it wasn't that
amazing or anything,
but there's something I did
differently because of it.
And in the case of this book,
"The Happiness of Pursuit,"
I didn't want to just
write a travel memoir.
I didn't want to just say,
here are Chris's stories
of traveling the world.
I wanted to present this
prescriptive message,
and that message is that a quest
can bring purpose and meaning
to your life.
And embracing the
value of adventure
or cultivating the value
of adventure in your life
is a good thing.
And so I think there's
a quest for all of you.
I think there's an adventure
of some kind for all of you,
whatever that looks like.
That's what I'm trying to
encourage or advocate for.
I think there's a princess
you have to rescue.
I think there's a
galaxy you need to save.
And then the last
thing I learned
was once you go down the road
of adventure-- 10 years ago,
I said yes to this adventure--
and once you go down
the road of adventure,
you don't always
know where you're
going to end up.
But you never know.
It could bring you to Mountain
View, California, here,
this afternoon, where
we're all having lunch.
And I'm grateful to
Rachel for hosting us,
and I'm grateful to all of you.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
RACHEL O'MEARA:
[INAUDIBLE] questions,
and I'll have to just pass
this mic around so that we
can capture you on audio for
the livestream and on video.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
My name's Sean.
I was most curious about
your travel to so-called more
dangerous countries,
such as North Korea.
It's always been a
fascination of mine
to go there, to go to Iran.
I've had a lot of
friends from there.
Tell me about your trip to
North Korea specifically.
CHRIS GUILLEBEAU:
Well, I'll tell you
about dangerous countries
in general to start with.
So the first thing is
there's actually not
a ton of dangerous
countries in the world.
It's a pretty short list.
I think it's important
to highlight that.
So there's 193
countries in the world.
As an American or
Canadian-- as a westerner
with those passports--
you can pretty much
go to 120 of them
no problem, easily.
You can go to another 40 of
them with a little bit of work,
like applying for a
visa or something.
So you're really only talking
about less than 10 countries,
I think, that are
actually difficult.
And there's always a way.
So with North Korea,
there's a tour
you can go on from Beijing.
And you fly to
Beijing, and you go
on this state sponsored tour.
That's the only way
to do it, essentially.
But you go on this
tour, and they'll
take your cell phone away from
you, and get it back later.
And it's all a little creepy,
but it's also interesting,
right?
As for Iran, the
other thing I learned
is that there's often more than
one way to go to somewhere.
Iran, there's an
island called Kish
which you can fly to from Dubai.
It's a visa free zone.
Anyone can go there.
So you actually don't have to
go through the normal process.
Somalia-- you can go to
Somaliland, which is still
very much a culturally,
ethnically authentic part
of Somalia, but it's also
autonomous politically,
and so it's much safer.
So actually, when I went to
Somalia, I went to Somaliland.
So I guess through studying
each particular place
and figuring out, OK,
what are the obstacles?
What are the challenges?
That's how I'm going to
overcome that and go there.
Thanks, Sean.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I guess my question
kind of revolves around-- we
all have these
great ideas, right?
And at the same time, we have
responsibilities and mortgages
and whatever.
So I guess I'm just wondering
what your advice is to people
who want to go out and
pursue certain things,
but there are also certain
limitations, I guess,
that we have to exist within.
I mean, I guess we don't, but
I can't walk away from my condo
tomorrow and walk
across the country.
It probably wouldn't
work out well for me.
But yeah.
What's your advice?
CHRIS GUILLEBEAU:
That's a great question.
But do you want to walk
across the country?
Is that your aspiration?
So I'm a big fan of
defining our aspirations
and then crafting our life
around them, essentially.
And so the quest to visit
every country in the world,
for example-- I was thinking
about this the other day,
because people ask
how much it cost.
And the first 100 countries
cost about $30,000.
So $30,000, at
least I would argue,
is not a huge amount
of money for going
to 100 countries and
all the life experience
that I got through that.
And also, I didn't have
to pay it all right away.
You pay as you go, essentially,
on something like that.
So these limitations, as
you said-- maybe let's
not call them limitations.
They're responsibilities,
especially
people with families.
You don't just leave your family
and walk across the country.
But, again, there
are ways to cultivate
the value of adventure.
That's why I like the story of
Sasha and what she did at home.
There's a woman in Omaha
who's knitting 10,000 hats.
Her passion, the thing
that she really loved,
was always knitting.
And one Christmastime
or holiday time, she
made 100 hats for her
friends and family.
And she was like,
that's really fun.
I want to do 1,000.
But 1,000 is not a
big enough challenge,
so she took on this
goal of 10,000 hats.
And there's a charity
component to it.
You can connect with
her o n her website
and eventually get a hat.
So, I mean, I don't know.
Responsibilities
and things are real,
but if something
matters to us, I
guess I'm also a believer in
figuring out how to do that,
right?
We do have to trade off things.
We do have to sacrifice.
And especially for all of us
with so many opportunities
available to us, it's a
matter of prioritization.
It's a matter of I can
probably do anything I want,
but I can't do
everything, right?
So if this thing really
does matter to me,
whether it's walking
across the country
or whatever it is in
your case, then it's
something that you have
to plan for and build for.
And for me, it was
worth it to do that.
AUDIENCE: But whose definition
of a country did you use?
CHRIS GUILLEBEAU: Oh, great.
Whose definition of a country?
I used the UN
definition's of a country.
So I used the 193
UN member states.
And there are a few different
competing definitions
of states and
countries, but I just
decided to be consistent
and go with that.
The followup that's
often asked is,
what happens if a new
country is added, you know?
And that did happen once.
So South Sudan
gained independence
about four years ago, and so
I did I did visit South Sudan.
The original goal was to go to
192, and then it became 193.
AUDIENCE: So I think a lot
of what you're talking about
has a lot of
sticktoitiveness-- like,
the grit that is over
a long period of time.
And you always have
these situations
where you have this really
intense aspiration that kind of
peters out after a while.
Do you have any
situations where you
started very strongly
believing in something
and wanting to hit
that goal, and then
deciding, maybe
this isn't for me?
CHRIS GUILLEBEAU: Yes.
Fantastic question.
What happens if your
motivation peters out?
I think a couple of things.
I think it depends on how
far along you are, maybe.
And I think it also depends
on what the long term
outcome is of what you're doing.
I'll give you a
couple of examples.
In my case, it was
a 10 year thing.
So I think if I didn't have
motivation in year two,
I think the best advice
would be just give up
and do something
different, and that's OK.
Like, I think it's terrible
advice to say never give up.
If you're doing
something that sucks
or you don't believe
in it, if you
don't have the motivation,
why continue, right?
And I think it's totally normal
to change course and do that.
But maybe if it was year
9 of my 10 year thing,
maybe the best advice
would be just keep going,
because you're almost there.
So I'll tell you one
story from the book.
There's this guy named Mark
Boyle, and he's from England.
And his original quest was
to walk from England to India
without spending any money.
So he thought this was
a great idea at first.
And he was a hero
in his hometown,
and people were
buying him beers,
and like, yeah, that's
great, you know?
And then he leaves England
and he finds pretty quickly
that the whole concept
doesn't really translate.
And he can't speak the language,
and people think he's a beggar.
And the whole point he's
trying to barter his work.
And that's his whole project.
But it didn't work, essentially.
And so about three weeks after
leaving England, he gave up.
He did go back home.
He's kind of
embarrassed and ashamed.
But then he started
thinking, OK,
what was the underlying
value of this goal?
It wasn't really
about walking to India
without spending money.
What he believed in was
this world without currency.
Or at least he believed in
this idea that some of us,
at least, could live in a
world without spending money.
And so he adjusted
his quest, and he
decided to live in
England for three years
without spending money.
And that was something
that was possible.
And he created this
whole barter economy
and attracted a lot of
people to his cause,
and just lived very simply.
So I think it's also OK to
change course and change
directions if something
doesn't work out.
That's the short version.
AUDIENCE: I assume you're
familiar with the work
of Joseph Campbell
and the hero myth,
and also Matt Dances
Around the World.
And so I was wondering
if you have any thoughts
on either of those two.
CHRIS GUILLEBEAU: On
either of those two.
That's a good little mashup.
Joseph Campbell,
the hero's myth.
A lot of what I'm talking
about, quests and adventures,
is something that has existed
for a long period of time.
I guess what I'm trying to do
is apply more of a modern day
twist to it and talk about
real life adventures, not just
mythological stories.
But as for Matt dances
around the world,
I believe the website's
wherethehellismatt.com.
He's had a wonderful
quest of not just gaining
fame and notoriety,
but exploring culture
around the world and dancing.
I don't actually
know him super great,
but I think it's a fun project.
AUDIENCE: I've been a longtime
blog reader of yours, actually,
and I know that your
total identity revolves
around a couple of things.
You're a writer, you're a
traveler, an entrepreneur.
You were also a pretty
serious runner for some time.
And I remember one blog post
you wrote a little while back
about how you look
back on some things
that you wish you had followed
through better on, right?
Because I remember you
mentioned that you didn't really
believe in balance.
You believed in doing
everything that you
could as best as you could,
et cetera, et cetera.
And so on the topic
of prioritization,
I was just wondering
what principles
you used to prioritize
and deprioritize
these aspects of your
identity, and how
you deal with the struggle of
wishing that you would have
maybe followed through on
another part of your identity
moreso while you
were prioritizing
writing or traveling.
CHRIS GUILLEBEAU: Yeah.
That's great.
Thank you for sharing
that, and thank you
for reading the blog as well.
I appreciate that.
I don't think I could say I
was ever a serious runner.
I was a pretty
serious 5K runner.
I would run three
miles really seriously.
I ran some marathons,
but it was hard.
Yeah.
I mean, not everything
worked out super great.
And lots of things
I do kind of wish,
oh, I wish I had
built that better.
I did have to make
a lot of tradeoffs.
And as I was coming to the
end of the quest, like,
my business is doing
well, and I have
all these different
opportunities to do things.
And I'm really good
at starting things,
and I'm not so great at
seeing them through, right?
So these are all these
weaknesses and strengths.
I guess what I loved so much
about the ten year quest was
I always knew what to do next.
And I would go away at
the end of the year,
and I would plan my
year, and I'd look ahead
at all the different
projects, and everywhere I
wanted to go, and
everything I wanted to do.
But I had this constraint.
Maybe I'll use the
word limitation again,
but in a positive way.
I had this constraint
of like, OK, I
have to go to 18
countries next year.
And again, just like Nate
walking across the country,
all I have to do is walk.
All I have to do is keep
making progress on that.
So the quest was an anchor.
It was like a foundation
for all of that.
And even though my identity,
just like everyone's identity,
is complex, and we do
lots of different things,
it was a perfect
central point from which
I could do a bunch of
other stuff as well.
So then I came to the end, and
I don't have the quest anymore,
and it's more complicated.
But that's the short part.
AUDIENCE: Now that
you've iterated once,
I want to know if
there's any place where
you feel you have some
unfinished business that you
feel a need to return to.
CHRIS GUILLEBEAU: Any
unfinished business?
You know, the great
thing about traveling
is you don't have to do
everything all at once.
And there were a number
of places that I went to,
and I was like, oh, I would
love to spend more time here,
or something.
But then the whole
point was I can go back.
I knew that.
I wasn't troubled by only
being in a place for a week
or something, when I wanted
to be there for a month.
So I don't know if it's
unfinished business,
but there's a number
of places in the world
that I felt a special attachment
to that I hope to return to.
So a few of those would be
Bhutan, in Southeast Asia.
I had a wonderful
experience there.
Macedonia and Lithuania are two
really small European countries
that, for some reason, I
just had a great time in,
and I would love to return to.
I haven't been
back to West Africa
in a number of years,
since I was living there.
I would like to return.
And I also just like
the process of travel.
And that was a good thing,
since I was always traveling.
So I liked the coming
and going to places,
and being in transit and motion.
And it wasn't all about
the destination for me.
It very much was
about the journey.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So my last day at
Google is Thursday,
not to make this about
me, but I kind of
have an unstructured
quest in the works.
And one of the things
I'm most afraid about
is being alone
traveling, and I wonder
if you can talk about that
challenge in particular,
and maybe how you dealt with it.
CHRIS GUILLEBEAU: Sure.
I think traveling
alone is wonderful.
I really do.
I mean, I have
traveled with others.
I've traveled in groups.
And I think it's good to mix it
up and do things differently.
But I kind of like
traveling alone.
And I think when
you travel alone,
you experience, sometimes,
a kind of loneliness
that is not always bad.
You experience an isolation,
in some ways, that
can be helpful and
reflective, and you also
don't have to be alone
if you don't want to.
I mean, these days, this
interconnected world,
with couch surfing, with social
networking, lots of meet up
groups everywhere-- like,
anything you want to do,
you can.
But I also think maybe
it's good to try it
out a little bit on your own.
You've traveled on your
own, haven't you, Rachel?
RACHEL O'MEARA: Yeah.
CHRIS GUILLEBEAU: Did you
have a good experience?
RACHEL O'MEARA: Yeah.
I've traveled a two month
[INAUDIBLE] on my own,
and here and there in India.
And I would say just
go with your gut,
and do a little planning.
I like to do a
framework and be like,
I'm gonna go in and
try it from there.
CHRIS GUILLEBEAU: That's great.
Congratulations on
your transition.
All the best.
That's great.
AUDIENCE: I was curious about
setting a goal for your quest.
You can do it two ways.
One is you either one big goal,
like climbing Mount Everest
or getting a new job, or a
bunch of smaller incremental
[INAUDIBLE] along the way,
like climb 10 mountains.
How would you think
about both those?
CHRIS GUILLEBEAU: How would
I think about both of those?
Well, I guess I
like them in tandem.
I guess the general principle
is I am pro-goal, right?
I am pro-parameters, you know?
There's this good story in the
book about a woman named Elise
[INAUDIBLE] who's
a serial crafter,
and she makes all this
stuff, and she shares it
with the world, and she's
incredibly prolific.
And her whole advice is
she says people are always
telling you to think
outside the box.
She says, my advice is to
get in the box, basically.
Make yourself a box.
Make yourself these parameters,
these goals, whatever.
Again, it's not something
that's being imposed on you.
That's really the clear point.
It's not like someone
saying, here's your goal.
Here's what you should do.
No, it's you.
It's things that you
select for yourself.
But I believe there's so much
possibility in those parameters
or in those constraints,
as we talked about.
So whether it's like, my goal
is to climb Mount Everest,
or maybe it's the 10
mountains, or something.
And stages are also good.
So stages are milestones--
the levels in Mario Brothers.
For me, it was
like, 50 countries.
100 countries.
Then it was like,
every continent.
Once I finished all of
Africa, that was a big thing.
So I do think it's
important to celebrate
small wins along the way.
AUDIENCE: So what
advice do you have?
CHRIS GUILLEBEAU: OK, great.
So, writing a
book-- was that part
of the quest, or something
that came afterwards?
And for those who want to write
a book, what advice do I have?
I don't know if it
was part of the quest.
What was your name again?
AUDIENCE: Jay.
CHRIS GUILLEBEAU:
Jay said something
about how I don't
believe in balance.
I believe in alignment
or convergence.
Everything that I do, I try to
relate in some way to another.
So I knew as I was coming
to the end of the journey,
I wanted to write a book.
I knew I didn't want it
to just be all about me.
But I don't know if it
was part of the quest.
As for advice on
writing books, there's
a lot we could say about that.
I would say I could start
with some mechanics,
and say that the
mechanical thing that
helped me the most for writing
books over the past few years
is to have a quota.
Again, a rule or a parameter.
And I had this quota of
a thousand words a day.
And if I'm in a book
writing mode, it's like, OK,
a nonfiction book is
about 70,000 words.
So I can write about
1,000 words a day.
Obviously, I'm not going
to write every day,
and there's going to be
a whole editing phase.
There's all kinds of other
stuff that comes later.
But the first goal is really
to capture that outline
and to understand what I
want to communicate, and then
to get the first draft down.
So I'm going to work
toward that in stages,
just like I do everything else.
That's the mechanical advice.
Maybe the more
important advice is
to know what you want
to say, and to really
start with a clear idea.
And if you have the
idea, I feel like so much
can flow from that.
And you don't have to have
a ton of ideas, either.
I feel like in my first book,
I didn't have one big idea.
I just had a whole
lot of things,
and I was kind of throwing it
all out, and that was great.
But I think it's a lot easier
if you just have one clear idea,
and then you can
extrapolate from that.
Are there other authors here?
Well, soon there will be.
That's great.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
re-write code.
CHRIS GUILLEBEAU: That's right.
I know.
That's great.
Rachel, you had a question.
Sorry.
That's great.
AUDIENCE: So I had a question.
I have two questions.
So the first question is,
in terms of prep-- so,
going to different countries--
what do you allow for yourself?
Are you prepping?
Does it depend on
the type of country?
Are you just going to
wing it a couple times?
Did you try everything?
I'm just really curious to
know what your planning was.
CHRIS GUILLEBEAU: Yep, yep.
I did try everything,
and I think
it kind of evolved a
little bit as I went along.
So in the beginning
of my travels,
I did a lot more research
than I did toward the end.
In the beginning,
I was all like, I'm
going to read up on my
Lonely Planet or whatever.
I'm going to find the top five
things I want to do there.
And I started doing that less
and less as I went along.
And I also started lightening
up a little bit more,
because I was really
an anxious person.
I was always worried
about lots of stuff.
And so, ironically,
actually, I had more things
that went wrong toward
the end of the journey
than I did in the beginning.
And I think it's because
in the beginning,
I was like super
worried all the time,
and I was double checking
everything and triple checking
things.
And at the end, I was
just like, I don't care,
because it's going to be fine.
If I miss the flight, whatever.
If I don't have the visa,
I'll figure something out.
So I kind of gained
confidence along the way,
and I also stopped planning.
And so I would go to
countries and just be.
And I would go on long walks.
And I often knew readers there,
because of the community.
So through Twitter
or through my blog,
I might connect with
someone locally,
and they would show me
around, and I would probably
have a much better
experience than I
would have had I done
hours of research
in advance, because they're
going to show me something
that's authentic and natural.
AUDIENCE: That's great.
And then my other question is
more on a philosophical level
of just learning about yourself.
So everyone who
travels, I think, really
comes in touch with
what's going on with them.
So what would you
say you tapped into?
Or did you find another part
of yourself in a journey
that you weren't aware of,
or that you didn't know?
And would you mind sharing that?
CHRIS GUILLEBEAU: No.
I didn't learn anything.
No, probably the greatest
change or transformation for me
was in going from,
like, this is just
something I'm doing for myself
because I believe in it,
and I think that's also good.
I think that's OK.
I don't think every
quest or adventure
has to have a super
humanity backdrop behind it.
I think it's OK to pursue
something that you believe in.
But having said that, for
me, the greatest change was I
started doing this by
myself, for the most part.
And then I did begin to connect
with this great community
of awesome people
who read the blog
and are doing awesome
things of their own.
And that just changed the
whole trajectory of the project
for me.
It changed the
whole focus for me,
and it helped me understand
just how much more important
that is.
And ultimately, I hope,
like-- visiting every country
in the world, I'm
super glad I did it.
No regrets.
But I think hopefully, that's
more like a footnote in my life
later, because so many
better things are coming out
of all these other things
that people are doing.
So that's more of my focus
now, a that was the big change.
AUDIENCE: So I heard
about that guy that
walked talking
for awhile on NPR.
For some reason, it
felt like I knew him
after I heard the
audio article on him.
Tell me about your
experience with that guy.
CHRIS GUILLEBEAU: That
guy was John Francis.
As I said, he was an
environmental activist.
He has a project
called Planet Walker.
And he actually has a new
project with an Indiegogo
that's happening now.
Yeah, he was, as I said,
initially disturbed
by this oil spill, and his
first goal was actually
to stop using
motorized transport.
He was like, I'm
just going to start
walking everywhere
and not taking cars.
And he did that for a while.
And then he felt
like he was having
to explain himself all the time.
And he felt that some
people were kind of offended
at his goal, because he felt
like he was judging them
or something-- that's
what they perceived.
They thought because
he wasn't taking cars,
they thought they were bad
or something for doing so.
So he just decided to kind
of cut that whole thing out,
and he did a silent retreat
for two or three days,
and then decided to keep going.
And he just did that for a
year, and then two years,
and it went on for
more than a decade.
And he traveled with a banjo.
So he started walking
across America,
and he enrolled in
a graduate program,
and he learned all
these different ways
of communicating with people.
So he's got an interesting
story of his own,
but you can learn
more at Planet Walker.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
what your interaction--
CHRIS GUILLEBEAU: What my
interaction with him was?
AUDIENCE: Was he
speaking at the time?
CHRIS GUILLEBEAU: He was
speaking at the time, yeah.
I wasn't his first
words or anything.
I think he called
his mother first.
He decided to call his mother.
Yeah.
He's just a very gentle
soul, as you would expect.
But he also has a
great sense of humor.
We do this event
every year in Portland
called World Domination
Summit, and he was actually
a speaker at that this year.
So there's a video up
online, if you want to see.
RACHEL O'MEARA: Thank you so
much, Chris, for coming today.
CHRIS GUILLEBEAU: Thank you.
Thank you guys.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.